on this Wednesday night Ottawa's 107
billion dollar emergency aid package who
will get it how much and when we know
people are anxious tougher measures for
travelers returning to Canada now
ordered not asked to self isolate for
two weeks you have to pretend that you
are actually holding the virus
how will the quarantine order be
enforced proof no one is immune everyone
is vulnerable
Prince Charles test positive for kovat
19 what about his mother the Queen plus
deepening despair ventilators
ventilators ventilators we need 30,000
desperation as New York City's morgues
will soon reach full capacity
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is relief on the way if you have
been laid off or can't work because of
Kovan 19:00 we have some important
details tonight about the federal
legislation passed in Parliament
overnight it's called the Canada
emergency response benefit and it will
inject billions into the economy that
includes $2,000 per month for the next
four months for workers affected by
kovat 19 this virus has killed business
and this emergency aid package totaling
107 billion dollars is designed to help
individuals and businesses by delivering
direct support and tax deferrals we are
working in order to make sure that we
have the capacity to protect Canadians
to get ourselves through this and to
come out of this challenge this is we
expect a very challenging time but a
temporary time to come out of this
challenge with our economy intact we
know many Canadians need the money now
with rent and bills to pay but the
checks aren't going out tomorrow Mike
look at aura has more on what the
government is saying about the timeline
help is on the way the government is
trying to reassure Canadians who have
already missed a paycheck because of the
kovat 19 outbreak releasing the details
of the aid package and exactly who it
will help whether you're full-time
contract or self-employed this new
benefit will be there for you if you're
sick or quarantined looking after
someone's sick or at home taking care of
your kids it's there for you the
candidate emergency response benefit
also applies to people who have yet to
be laid off but aren't getting any
income because of this crisis it covers
a lot of people who need money now and
that's the biggest problem
now the government online portal to
apply for these benefits is scheduled to
be up and running by April 6th and the
prime minister has promised money in
your pockets within ten days of applying
for it meaning financial help is still
three weeks away but questioned about
that delay in a special Senate session
Finance Minister Bill Morneau explained
they're doing the best they can there
art
ways to get money in Canadians hands
that is in fact the challenge that we're
facing in this particular situation 1.1
million Canadians have filed for
employment insurance since last week and
that number is expected to grow the
prime minister says 1,300 civil servants
have been brought in to help process all
those claims and to prevent more claims
business groups say the government could
have used companies to funnel the money
to Canadians and avoid more layoffs we
can avoid that by executing
expeditiously with a greater sense of
urgency and working collaboratively
together with business so that we can
keep these employees on a payroll and
not have to have them go through an
arduous AI process if at all possible
the finance minister admits the systems
that will deliver these government
services we're not built for the type of
stress and strain they are about to
endure and that's why the government
feels it was so important for Parliament
to sit through the night so Canadians
can get the benefits as soon as possible
Donna Michael cutter in Ottawa thank you
here's how many people are diagnosed
with kovat 19 in Canada right now there
are more than 3,300 confirmed cases
across the country more than 30 people
have died and the spread of the virus is
accelerating so far today at least 610
new cases have been reported Ontario had
its biggest daily jump yet 100 new cases
and that brings the total number in that
province to 688 17 of those people are
in intensive care in Newfoundland and
Labrador the number of cases nearly
doubled today 67 people now have tested
positive 44 of them have been linked to
a funeral home in Saint John's
it's believed someone with koban 19 went
to the funeral home last week exposing
others to the virus people across
Newfoundland and Labrador being urged to
stay home the safe thing for you to do
now is assume that there's Co vyd around
you and to stay home and stay apart but
stay connected
a Canadian member of parliament has
kovat 19 kemal Cara is the first MP to
test positive she is a two-term Liberal
MP from Brampton West Ontario and a
registered nurse she
we did she's experiencing symptoms but
is in good spirits as our chief
political correspondent David akin
reports what's concerning is who she's
been in contact with over the last two
weeks it was March 11th when Brampton
West MP Camille Cara met the executive
director of the United Nations World
Food Program David Beasley at a
Parliament Hill reception then eight
days later on March 19th
Beasley said he had tested positive for
kovat 19 and had been in quarantine for
five days that meant Beasley would have
been in self quarantine on March 14th
three days after the reception in Ottawa
but on March 17th Kara announced that as
a registered nurse she was volunteering
to be on the frontline to fight the
virus in Brampton it's not known if Kara
did any frontline nursing work then or
after Beasley announced his positive
test and she did not respond to
inquiries from Global News Beasley also
met with as many as 50 MPs during his
official visit to Canada some of those
MPs have been in self isolation ever
since though Kara is the only MP so far
to have been confirmed positive for
kovat 19 and all of this of course
underlines the risk politicians face and
the risk politicians represent because
of course politics is a social business
and it like so many other businesses is
now undergoing rapid change Donna all
right David akin in Ottawa thank you
efforts are still underway to bring home
Canadians who are stranded overseas
flights are starting to arrive from Peru
and Ukraine today more flights are in
the works from several other countries
in Latin America North Africa and Europe
priority is being given to places where
there are no or limited flight options
and where there is a critical mass of
Canadians trying to get out many will be
coming from places that have outbreaks
of kovat 19 like Spain and there are
still regularly scheduled flights coming
into Canada from all over the United
States today the government toughened
its approach to all those returning
travelers it is now mandatory under the
quarantine act to stay home and self
isolate for 14 days so there is perfect
clarity around the need to isolate when
Canadians come back from a
whether it's from the USA or other
international destinations we are
implementing the quarantine act so there
is no confusion about the need to do so
whether you are symptomatic or not
returning travelers with symptoms are
warned not to take public transportation
and not to self isolate where there are
vulnerable people when they land we're
told contact information will be taken
from symptomatic passengers and others
plus some random checks will be
performed but other than that it's not
clear how the quarantine act will be
enforced might relay reports Canadians
returning from abroad expected extensive
testing for kovat 19 symptoms upon
landing when we heard Prime Minister
Trudeau speak we were almost thinking
they're gonna have like thermal imaging
to see if you have a fever or they're
gonna take your temperature or something
at the airports but none of that there
was nothing over the past week Canadians
have been given this single information
sheet a number of travelers interviewed
by global news report the same things
few masks fewer questions and almost no
social distancing well you know what it
is it's a flying petri dish and the
airports are breeding for very fertile
breeding ground for Kovac 19 : McCaskill
and her family went into isolation but
not everyone is heated the advice of
health officials so now the federal
government says it will use the
quarantine act to force travelers to
isolate the penalties for contravening
the order include a million dollar fine
and three years in jail I think all of
us are going to be and feel safer with
mandatory quarantine for anyone entering
Canada but how will the quarantine act
be enforced and will Canadians respected
we've spoken to several travelers who
say they do anything to return to Canada
including masking any symptoms they may
have over a million people were screened
for fevers and airports during the SARS
crisis with no positive tests and Canada
Border Services is investigating how a
72 year old woman with kovat symptoms
was able to fly undetected into Toronto
last weekend only to die hours later
well at this stage with crisis
and everybody wanting to get home we
cannot rely on that honor system I hate
to say it we're human and humans
sometimes need motivation to do the
right thing
microlight global news toronto we know
no one is immune to this virus not even
a prince the heir to the British throne
Prince Charles has tested positive one
of more than 9,000 cases in the UK he's
71 years old he's said to be doing well
the worry is not just about him but only
other people he's interacted with
recently including his mother the Queen
crystal commencing reports this is the
Prince of Wales avoiding handshakes
during one of his most recent public
appearances it was very shocking news
that Prince Charles tested positive for
he's probably one of the most
high-profile people in the world who's
now got the virus but the good news is
that he's supposed to have fairly minor
symptoms his wife Camilla tested
negative the couple is now in isolation
in Scotland it's not known where Prince
Charles picked up the virus but he's
been at many events including one
earlier this month with Prince Albert of
Monaco who tested positive on the 12th
the 12th is also the last time Prince
Charles saw his mother the Queen is in
good health
according to Buckingham Palace as is her
98 year old husband Prince Philip
Windsor Castle in lockdown and they're
just being served by a very small staff
of clothes they eat only about something
British Prime Minister Boris Johnson did
not see the Queen for their regular
meeting they spoke over the telephone a
lockdown is in place in the UK in an
effort to save lives more than 400 here
have already died of the virus crystal
de Manson Global News London
India is taking a tough approach to
enforcing the lockdown in that country
which is in place for 21 days police are
out in force wearing masks and
physically punishing those who are
breaking the rules and going out
roadblocks are in place in all 1.3
billion people except essential workers
have been told to stay home only about
600 people have tested
in India but it's expected that number
will spike and hospitals were soon be
overwhelmed fears kovat 19 could
penetrate prisons coming up the drastic
plan to prevent inmates from getting
infected
police are patrolling the streets of New
York City the epicenter of the outbreak
in the United States
anyone who has recently been to that
city is being asked to self quarantine
for two weeks and in Washington
lawmakers passed a two trillion dollar
emergency relief bill it is the biggest
in American history and it did give the
markets a boost the TSX closed up 568
points today ending the day at over
13,000 the Dow Jones climbed 495 points
to close at just over 21,000 New York
state's governor though says that bill
doesn't give his state nearly enough
money to deal with the crisis
Jackson prosecco reports in New York
State the situation grows worse by the
day the number of confirmed cases is
more than 30,000 and rising New York
City morgues are reportedly nearing
capacity ventilators ventilators
ventilators we need 30,000 medical
workers are already reusing masks and
conserving the supplies they have mouths
of stress in neighboring New Jersey
doctors at one Hospital say the ten
ventilators they have simply won't be
enough the only good news restrictive
social distancing measures may be
working the rate of hospitalization has
slowed slightly New York City is now
preparing to close some of its busiest
roads to make more room for pedestrians
to space themselves out as anyone
leaving the city is asked to self
quarantine for two weeks we mandated the
isolation of all individuals that fly to
Florida from the New York City area
similar outbreaks are growing in
communities across the u.s. Louisiana
has seen its numbers surge help is on
the way in Washington urgency has led to
a rare show of unity as lawmakers reach
a deal on a two trillion dollar relief
package one that will include direct
payments to Americans and bailouts for
businesses big and small this is not
even a stimulus package it is emergency
relief
late today the president tweeted that
quote the media is the dominant force in
trying to keep him to get him to keep
the country closed in the interests of
damaging his prospects at reelection
Donna that's obviously not true it's
state and local officials who are
listening to public health guidance and
those public health officials say half
if not more of the cases they're seeing
of confirmed coronavirus right now are
in young people under the age of 50 yeah
that is deeply worrying Jackson Prosecco
in Washington thank you there are
warnings tonight of a potential disaster
across the American prison system
because of kovat 19 there are already a
number of positive cases among inmates
and staff and overcrowded conditions are
fueling the spread of the virus several
states have already started to release
thousands of inmates hit when they're
down still ahead how can Alberta's
energy sector survive this before this
pandemic Alberta's energy sector was
already under the weather hit by falling
oil prices and a lack of pipeline
capacity today Canada's finance minister
said financial help is coming for the
oil and gas industry I'm not talking
about weeks I'm talking about hours
potentially days that we can ensure that
there's credit facilities for especially
the small and medium sized firms in that
sector right now the fate of multiple
projects in Alberta is uncertain as
Heather Eurex west reports Alberta's
premier says the economic hit will be
massive Chris might'n has been through
downturns in the energy sector before
the bust of 2015 almost cost him
everything barely back on his feet last
week he was laid off once again I was
notified by phone from my my direct
report that we won't be returning
because of the coal be thinking
collectively companies like Husky
Synovus and Canadian natural resources
have cut billions in spending following
a collapse in oil prices
unlike the industry has ever seen
previous crashes have been serious for
the oil and gas industry but what we're
seeing here is unprecedented we just
don't know what's going to be happening
in the mid-80s Alberta's economy went
into recession when the price of West
Texas Intermediate hovered just above 11
dollars a barrel or about $24 in today's
terms 30 years later in 2015 global oil
prices tanked again tens of thousands of
jobs were lost when prices for a barrel
of Western Canada select fell to around
$16 a barrel at one point last week that
same barrel cost a little more than $5
it's like the same price is a cup of
coffee it's it's it's incredible while
kovat 19 has sent global demand for oil
off a cliff a spat between Saudi
Arabia's OPEC and Russia has also led to
the market being over supplied Alberta's
premier warns these record low prices
could get worse Citibank is projecting
that Brent oil could be trading on
average as low as $5 in the second
quarter of this year which would
probably mean that we would be paying
people to take Alberta oil off our hands
the federal government says help is
coming details of a 15 billion dollar
aid package are expected to be released
this week while the Alberta government
has enlisted the help of former Prime
Minister Stephen Harper to help them
navigate these uncharted waters
Chris Myton hopes people like him are
not forgotten as an independent
contractor he isn't even eligible for AI
just the financial support being a
contractor is tough Heather York's West
Global News Calgary Hannah's coronavirus
survive a hot shower next experts answer
your questions
we've been trying to ease some of the
uncertainty and the confusion you may
have and probably have about this
pandemic many of you have submitted
questions through our website and our
Jeff sample has been putting together
some of those questions to the experts
take a look and a listen across the
country
Canada's normally bustling streets are
silent Canadians heeding the call to
stay indoors like Paula Anderson from
Grand Prairie we had come back from a
family holiday in Mexico and gone into
self-isolation
the end of that period is just coming up
this week
now is not the time to go and visit your
other family members you know we
understand there has to be some kind of
essential things to know going to get
groceries sometimes people have to go to
certain types of doctor appointments but
you know if you're going to go outside
what we recommend is that you go outside
but you keep yourself away at least two
meters for everybody else others are in
salt isolation because they developed
symptoms consistent with kovat 19 like
hillary from hamilton there are some
scattered reports of a virus being
detected by molecular testing on people
who are several days past 14 days
several days passed to discharge from
the hospital and were deemed to be
recovered one study found that once
infected patients develop symptoms
they're contagious for about eight days
besides social distancing a lot of
viewers are asking how to make sure they
don't bring the virus home and are
wondering if it might help to turn up
thank you
this is Roger in Chilliwack DC I know
one common question a lot of people have
is temperature as far as personal
hygiene and grooming taking hot showers
and so on what is the best way to make
sure that you're doing your part to to
be able to sanitize surfaces and
yourself
other viewers are asking about killing
the virus with hot water laundry even a
hot tub the SARS coronavirus can be
killed by temperatures of 56 degrees
Celsius but when this corona VAR as
higher humidity and temperature seem to
inhibit it on surfaces but water at any
temperature should do the trick if you
just add soap if your soap and water
it's all you have in your house use that
metal work soap water and social
distancing our best weapons against an
invisible threat Geoff sample Global
News Toronto Jeff will continue to
consult with experts and try to answer
your questions send them to your
questions at Global News CA and on our
website you'll find a special page
dedicated entirely to Cove in nineteen
that's at Global News CA / coronavirus
that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight we
leave you with an outpouring of support
from the BC legislature this pink
fountain just a small show of support
for all the health care workers putting
their lives on the line to save the rest
of us we salute them too thanks for
watching and take care of yourselves
[Music]